about 45 000 civilians have sought
shelter at un bases across south sudan
there's an acute shortage of water
medicine and food
as the violence spreads the u.n security
council has approved a plan to boost its
presence with around six thousand extra
peacekeepers and police
but secretary general ban ki-moon warns
that the united nations will not be able
to protect every civilian in need
i urge the leaders of south sudan to act
for peace
stop the violence
start the dialogue
save your proud and duly independent
country there is no time to lose
the fighting began with an alleged coup
attempt president salvakir accused his
rival former vice president riek masha
of attempting to seize power
violence is taking place along ethnic
lines between the majority dinka tribe
to which kia belongs and the newer which
is masha's community
the town of bor has seen heavy fighting
the government now says it's recaptured
the area from rebels i was informed
that
the loyal forces of this government
have taken war
and they are
now clearing whatever pockets that are
around war
the un estimates that thousands have
died already there are also reports of
mass graves
aid organizations fear a humanitarian
disaster in the world's newest country